hi i'm james crow at vanderbilt
university medical center and thanks for
joining us at lab roots 2021.
uh today i'll be
discussing uh the discovery and biology
of protective sars kovi to human
monoclonal antibodies
now of course we're all
pretty much done with uh hearing about
cova we've heard so much about
pandemic and we'd like to be over it but
i think
i'd like to use it really as a case
study in
current approaches to
discovering monoclonal antibodies and
how to characterize them and i'll be
talking about some
published
activities that we've had in the past
year
antibodies have gone on to the clinic
and been successful
and then some unpublished work on
new specificities
so
let me start with just the timeline
during the outbreak when
we were called upon to
conduct a rapid antibody discovery
program for source cov2
so we're part of a
darpa or u.s government dod
agency program called pandemic
prevention program
and the idea was to make antibodies
within 60 days
of an outbreak and we were simulating
outbreaks in
2019 and preparing for another
simulation in 2020 when in fact covet
occurred and we were called upon not to
simulate an outbreak but to respond to
an actual outbreak
the sample that um
that i'm going to speak about today
um came from individuals who were
infected in wu on china in december 2019
they
traveled to toronto canada
and by march they were convalescent they
were about 50 days out and so therefore
had circulating memory b cells
and so we obtained the sample
in collaboration with um investigators
in toronto that sample was lost for a
little bit of the airport eventually
arrived at nashville with the help of
fedex special operations
we expanded the b cells sorted them with
pre-fusion stabilized spike protein
that we've made recombinantly
then we used a microfluidic platform
called the beacon from berkeley lights
and this is a collaboration with
berkeley lights they brought in the
beacon to our
facility really about a week before we
started and sent in application
scientists
to work with us we did the single cell
cloning and obtain monoclonal antibodies
in the third week of march
and then obtain the
sequences twist bioscience synthesize
those for us into our expression vector
for immunoglobulins we did many
transfections and microscale
purifications
um
and started characterizing those
antibodies
we did neutralization assays
with
pseudotype viruses with chimeric vsv
viruses and with authentic viruses
in collaboration with mike diamond at
washu and all of those
assays were helpful although the
authentic virus really tells you
uh the the most accurate ic50 for
neutralization activity and also the
chimeric vsv's not the pseudotype virus
but the chimeric
replication competent
vsv's also give you an accurate ic50
once we
had done the screening after about two
days we knew we had very potent
antibodies uh we assembled the
neutralization and antibody data
and
down selected to sequences and we
transferred those to a farmer part
partner astrazeneca on april 8. so that
whole process from sample to lead
transfer to the pharma partner was done
in 25 days
we looked at these for in vivo
protection
in
various types of mice with michael
diamond and also ralph barrick at unc
and then ultimately in
primates with dan baruch so
this just shows you that
these sorts of single cell
rapid
processes can be done very quickly in a
matter of weeks
uh and these antibodies are not just
theoretical
um
reagent types of antibodies but they
actually were put into clinical trials
which have now been successful so to
give you a little more detail about how
this actually works the the beacon is a
microfluidic device which has little
pins each of those pins
um
is available to deposit a single b cell
in the bottom of the pen
and those b cells if they're activated
they fill up the pen very quickly in
about 20 minutes or definitely within an
hour with secreted antibody which spills
out into a main channel
and
we
put into the device
beads streptavidin beads that are
complexed in this case with spike
protein which captures the blue secreted
antibodies and then we were able to
detect
the secretion of specific antibodies
using an anti-igg secondary that's
conjugated
and on the top you can see binding to
spike protein or to the receptor binding
protein
the spectrobinding domain of the spike
protein that we made
and we found antibodies that would bind
either or both of those reagents
so this is a very effective
assay that could be performed very
quickly now just i i think it goes
almost without saying that the
the impact of next generation sequencing
which came from the human genome project
all of those instruments and technology
and also synthetic genomics revolution
which allowed us in particular with our
partner
twist to synthesize
antibody genes in in a matter of days
and put them into expression vectors so
when we see the next generation
sequencing not only have single cell we
can do bulk sequencing of entire
repertoires in peripheral blood and
generate genetic lineages
of somatic variance so on the left
you're seeing
a single clone or clonatype
it's really a clone in this this case
from a single person
with samples taken at different days
and the the individual antibody we we
got from a cell
shown as a little triangle but sequences
um were represented in the next
generation sequencing and we can make
all those as proteins thousands of
somatic variants and look at them
productivity
another
advance that
really made this possible
in this instance was using as i
mentioned before the replication
competent recombinant of the secular
stomatitis virus
competent viruses that were expressing
source cov2 spike protein
and these were
made by sean whalen's group at washu and
shared with us and
we have looked at the correlation
of authentic source cov2 neutralization
on the x-axis
and the activity is a log scale the
activity
against the replication competent vsv
and there's a linear correlation
so
uh paul rothloff and sean whalen
uh put these together and they've been
very helpful to us in the antibody
campaigns
another major advance for us was
something that was
really
discovered or invented in our group by
pablo gilchak who's a very talented
staff scientist at vanderbilt
who has been developing real-time
um assays for neutralization and this is
based on a principle called cell
impedance so we have an
instrument
um
built by a company a sia that is
basically a 96 or 384 well plate that
has chips in the bottom of them and
those measurable measure electrical
impulses and if cells cover the bottom
of the well
and make die junctions or at least seal
the cell to cell
adherence properties of a monolayer
then adherence goes up and so on the
x-axis over time
you see the the evolution of the
impedance on the y-axis is the impedance
measurements or the cell index is really
the value
and you can see as we put cells on from
zero to 24 hours cell of penis goes up
as the cells fill in
if we add virus
without any antibody you get a full
cytopathic effect and
the impedance goes back to zero but if
you have neutralizing antibodies as in
the green curve
you see that we maintain or even
increase the cell impedance and some
antibodies only partially protect which
is in the red curve so this is a
real-time assay that can read out very
quickly in about a day after we apply
the virus and we know
which antibodies are protecting and
again we did many uh correlations to
show that this
this real-time
assay correlates very well with
authentic virus nude vsv newts
nanoluciferase newts
with uh ralph barrick and so on
another thing that
helped us
during the early discovery was thinking
about combinations of antibodies with a
rational design not just throwing two
together but thinking about what is the
best way to do that and so on the left
elon benchteen and our group took
pairs of antibodies that we knew did not
compete
and
did single particle em reconstructions
of the binding of the fabs in this case
an fab called 2130 and yellow and 2196
and purple
complex at the same time on a
recombinant rbd antibody
um
or rbd domain excuse me and so both of
these are rbd antibodies but they they
are able to bind at the same time and
that gave us confidence that there was
enough
area on the rbd to accommodate two
antibodies and we look through and these
for two
particular antibodies on the right we
did what are called synergy
experiments in which you
on the x axis go from zero to a high
concentration in nanograms per ml of one
of the antibiotics 2196 on the y-axis
the same for the other antibody the
yellow 2130 from zero to high and you
can see you don't see any neutralization
at zero but there are
concentrations for instance eight
nanograms per ml here with 2196 where
you don't see any neutralization
and
at 63 nanograms per ml for 2130 no
neutralization but if you cross those
two
are very potent in and of themselves and
each one would probably be fine but
together we get even more bang for the
buck with this energy
and that's great
so
as i said we we did various types of
animal studies
in the beginning there were no
really good animal models
mike diamond took an adenovirus and
transduced the lung of live mice with
human ace2 which was rapidly determined
to be the receptor and of course mice
don't have human ace too with the
adenovirus transduction could put the
gene in there and now they have human h2
in their lung
and we could uh inoculate them with
multivirus and get replication and this
is the
the weight curve so and the animals lose
weight in the black curve but if we give
them either one of these antibodies i've
been talking about 2196 or 2130
we preserve
uh the the weight
and you could do various things like
histopathology so untreated you see
consolidation in the lung and lots of
lymphocytes whereas in the treated on
the bottom looks like a normal lung so
that's a good effect
we also
looked at these antibodies
even as monotherapy
in non-human primate models macaques
where we gave the antibody
the day before and then challenged with
authentic virus
and dan baruch's lab had developed a
subgenomic
rna test to look for newly made rna so
not the input rna but only newly made
and in neither the nose nor the
lungs do we see a single copy of rna
with with this antibody 2196 or a
similar antibody 2381 whereas in an
isotype control
treated
um
set of animals you see nice virus
shedding
in both the nose and the lungs so um
we're saying you know great protection
in small animals as well as not even
primates so this was a go signal that
this type of antibody with this type of
neutralization potency
uh was attractive to move forward
and so
many antibodies that we made at
vanderbilt were
looked at in preclinical studies and
down selected and then a handful has
been studied uh now in the clinic or is
in clinical development astrazeneca has
been our major partner and they've done
i think six or seven phase three trials
so far
uh in the proven trial
is a prevention trial that
has now been announced as effective with
i think 77 percent of protection against
any
um
covid infection symptoms at all
including upper respiratory tract after
prophylaxis
um the the jpo program
of dod
with the
their
manufacturerology also has made
a different antibody cocktail that's
being looked at on military personnel
and id biologics
is looking at another
set of antibodies so az has studied
these analyze all over the world and
multiple clinical trials
formats prevention
treatment trials are still ongoing
and so on
of course when
variants of interest and variance of
concern started coming out then it
became apparent that we needed to look
carefully at the epitopes
being recognized by these antibodies
because if variants of concern escape
the antibodies that are in development
they would no longer be very attractive
as therapeutic or prophylactic molecules
but in fact
we've now gotten the
co-crystal structure of 2196 which is
shown in pink and cyan
and 2130 which is in yellow and salmon
here on the rbd
in green so we get both fabs in complex
with receptor bonding domain as a single
macromolecular complex and did the
um the crystal structure at high
resolution
um
genuine dong did this in our lab and it
was recently published in nature
microbiology
and we can see the particular residues
that are recognized by these these fabs
and that's very helpful and then we can
go out and and look at um
various
point mutations that are occurring in
variants of concern shown in the various
columns
and we have compared
these antibodies 2196 2130 or the
combination which is what's being
developed clinically for
um change in activity
in um in ic50 and we can see these these
antibodies are still very very potent
single nanogram per ml ic50 i guess all
the variants we've tested including
delta which is the major variance
circulating in the u.s at this time so
these antibodies recognize highly
conserved residues
and that plays out in terms of as
predicted broad and potent neutralizing
activity um
now
we did not only make you know three or
four antibodies we made
thousands of antibodies to date and it's
interesting i need to pivot a little bit
and say other than the receptor binding
domain in which you see
both strain specific recognition
patterns and broad
recognition patterns
there are other
sites that are recognized in particular
the n-terminal domain and so i want to
look at that a little bit because i
think
these are occurring in people after
infection and also after vaccination
with a full
spike vaccine
and i think you want to be aware of
what's going on with ntt antibodies and
understand their their utility and their
limitations
so
um
so in the next section i'm going to talk
about human monoclonal antibodies
against the internal domain of spike
um now we we identified a large number
of um
of ntd antibodies i think well over
100 maybe maybe close to 200
but
most of them were not neutralizing
interestingly so they would
they would bind to
the
the ntd protein but not neutralized but
we found several
that
bound to spike protein the ectodomain
also to
just the
recombinant in the ntd portion of spike
protein
and
and also neutralized virus so that's
quite interesting because there's only a
very small subset of ntd antibodies that
potentially neutralizes
and
one of the reasons we think that ntd
is difficult to recognize
for neutralization
is because of the complex glycosylation
um
patterns on the spike protein and also
the the open and closed or up and down
positions
of spike so
guanabe and
science has shown these these patterns
of glycosylation and it's very complex
um but these two particular antibodies
uh that we focused on
uh that we're neutralizing if we do a
competition
experiment in which on the y-axis is the
second antibody the first antibody is a
blocking antibody and and look at which
antibodies compete with each other
these two antibodies are neutralized
they do compete with each other and so
they they recognize uh basically the
same
epitope or antigenic site at least and
we know that they do not block ace2
they're too far
a field for that so 2196 i showed you
before is an
h2 blocking rbd antibody but the ntd
antibiotics don't have that property
now we have gone on and
determined the structure of these in
complex
with spike protein and you can see
they're quite far off to the side
because of their
they're
recognizing the ntds so 2489 on the left
2676 in the center
the
the pink
or blue structures or the fabs and in
the center is the spike protein and if
we superimpose them you can see they
as suggested by the competition
data they are binding in a very similar
place
and
also
it's quite interesting if we look at the
the
antibody variable genes the the v genes
and the um of the heavy chain and the
light chain there is uh
diversity
being used there although if we look at
several other um ntd antibodies in the
literature from chiadal new at all
there are patterns where you see uh for
vh169
has a shared vh and this probably has to
do with the
hydrophobic cdr 2 that's encoded by
vh169 so there's some genetic diversity
of antibodies at the ntd for
neutralization but maybe some conserved
elements
um
we have gone on with um with integral
molecular bendorance and
edgar davidson in philadelphia
to do
single alanine
scanning single residue
mapping and we know the individual
residues if you change them to alanine
in the in a full library that abrogate
binding so the loss of binding residues
are shown up
in the top left and you can see their
position in the spike protein on the
side view or on the right
from the top view so they're quite
lateral and that fits with the single
particle em reconstruction that we saw
so we know exactly the residues that are
being recognized by these ntd antibodies
now um
not only can we do loss of binding with
alanine scanning another way to do
sort of functional mapping is to create
escape mutant viruses now i showed you
the real time assay before the rtca real
time cell analysis neutralization assay
with x
axis being the time and y-axis being the
cell impedance and you can see with
um
uh various
um
instances particular wells that we
pulled out of a 384 well plate the the
impedance goes up and then it falls back
down which it shouldn't do that because
these antibodies are neutralizing uh and
and the reduction in cell impedance
means that virus has escaped
um and so you can see whenever there's a
down arrow the impedance is going down
and so we generate escape mutating
mutations for these antibodies
which look very similar to no antibody
whereas if we use a 2196 rbd antibody
control cell impedance goes up
and so if we if we take the contents of
those wells and sequence them we can
determine the
the
sequence polymorphisms
that um
mediate escape and they're very similar
to the helene scanning
um
mutations that we occurred so this is a
functional mapping as well so you have
lots of binding or loss of
neutralization or two ways to do fine
epitope mapping
another thing we were trying to
understand the mechanism of action it's
pretty clear these antibodies you know
in a neutralization acid they don't need
the fc region at all
uh probably i mean they're not
interacting with fcr because there's no
there's no antigen presenting cells
there's no fcr bearing cells in the
assay but we were
interested in whether you needed
bivalent binding
and so we compared a a full wall type
igg with fab2 forms where we cut off the
fc or just an fab form and it's
interesting
the fabs
of these antibodies completely lose
activity the fab2 is a moderate
reduction and the wild type has full
activity so
we think that the
the size of the antibody not necessarily
the um
bivalent binding but the the size of the
antibody
probably
uh plays a role with ntd
and the smaller it is the less effect it
has
um
now we did take these antibodies uh into
animal models with
mike diamond again
and
and they do have a positive effect in
which we maintain the weight whereas
untreated animals
lose weight we decrease the virus and
especially lung
also to some degree in the nasal wash if
you do that prophylactically
and
you also see
you know a major effect doing therapy
one day later and again the
histopathology
much more open lungs when you're
antibody treated whereas you have
consolidated lungs which is pneumonia
with the isotope treated animals
and
we even looked out at
two days and there you see
not so much effect you do have a
survival benefit
but the the weight loss is quite severe
and the effect on viral titers is modest
and now you're picking up some some
histopathology not as bad as untreated
so the later you wait to treat with this
type of antibody the less effect you're
going to have and so
those are sort of exploratory um
studies that we did with um ntd
antibodies and then
we said well wow are there even
more anagenic sites in ntd than we
originally saw so i just want to
introduce you to another
technology called linking b-cell
receptor to antigen specificity through
sequencing or libra seek this was a a
new technology i reported in cell a year
or two ago by our colleague at
vanderbilt evelyn georgiev and his team
and so this is a technique in which
a dna barcode is added to a protein and
used for cell sorting
and then single cell
recovery of antibody genes so you take
an antigen
and then you
um
use an oligonucleotide or a dna barcode
and you you add that to the protein
antigen so now you have protein antigen
but it also has a dna that can be
recognized by pcr and sequencing
and
of course you can use a fluorophore
for sorting and so
by adding sorting and barcoding
activities you can
do flow sorting and then those
cells are put into
a single cell device for recovering
through single cell and seek typically
we're using 10x genomics
instrument and again this is the
reference from set lift
at all in cell 2020 about the actual
technique i think um neville's group did
it with flu and maybe hiv originally but
probably the project i'm showing you
today is
uh done with um
source cov2 and what's interesting is
evelyn's group had um
was able to barcode not only sarge cov2
in the first column but source 1
mers merge s1 domain
seasonal viruses like oc43 hku1 and even
hiv antigens as controls
and also because of the way the
sequencing is done you can see isotypes
like iggy iga1 a2 d
ig 1 2 3 and even igms
so here's the sorting where you you sort
um antigen positive
cells out of the cd19 positive b cell
population
and then you
um you can run
various populations through expansion
activation
in confirmation or directly into 10x
genomics
and
um we
were able to recognize with various
platforms
of course antibodies all over the place
um
and again this is the
panel of antigens that evelyn's group
was using
with
the donor cells and
these the panel of antigens was made by
jason mcclellan's lab ut austin
um
and so this is sort of a schematic of
how the
the labeling might be done with two
antigens but of course it could be done
with more than that
um mix the b cells or the antigens sort
pool 10x genomics next generation
sequencing and then a a proprietary
bioinformatics
program with libra seek to identify
now we looked at various donors that we
had been studying at the vanderbilt
vaccine center
post
covid or covet vaccination
and these are plasma or serum tests
using dilutions on the x-axis and
od
at 450 on the y-axis
and the sarsko v2 ntd is shown in green
and so we found this donor in 1989 who
had a relatively high
serum profile
for ntd
and
we went on and did authentic virus newt
on the left or
the recombinant
replication component vsv
neutralization assay on the right
and we looked at this individual
day 18 day 28 day 56 or
day 90 after infection
and the
seropositivity of neutralizing antibody
was quite high throughout all of the
course over the first three months
um and so we used uh b cells from this
individual
um to
look for
a prefusion stabilized
uh
six
six proline
stabilization
format the spike protein and also the
ntd
reagent and that way you can find
ntd specific that also bind to spike
protein we found 102 cells
um
that were igg one two or three and then
the rest we saw were a ga and b
and there's sort of two columns here
um
this is sarge you know cov2 rbd ntd
spike protein and stars one spike
protein and then repeating those
and then in and highlight are the ones
we found that were
neutralizing so we found more
neutralizing clones
we did various analyses most of these
interesting if you look at these violin
plots with identity and for germline are
in fact
nearly germline antibodies
we also looked at the ig
hv or the heavy chain variable gene
usage
of these antibodies
and
you see a wide diversity of antibodies
responding to ntd
but
in fact there's some over-represented
genes
that are 169 or 124 that are seen
more than others
and the 124 turns out to be a public
cloneotype where we see a handful of
antibodies that use that
that particular
antibody variable gene and
they bind to ntd and spike protein
and the bioinformatics cores are quite
high so it's interesting there appears
to be a public cloneotype that binds to
ntd
if we look at these antibodies by
binding
and
and then calculate from the binding
curves
the
ec50 of binding they bind quite well if
we calculate nanogram per ml ic50 of
neutralization on the right we see some
of these are single-digit or in the
teens for neutralization so they're very
potent antibodies
even though they're to ntd again they're
a small subset of ntd antibodies but it
shows you that
the initial report said ntd was not
really a neutralizing target are not
true it's just that there's a small
subset of antibodies induced by
infection that are neutralizing now we
did again the competition assays that
i've mentioned before
with a first antibody that's unlabeled a
blocking antibody now on the x-axis same
antibodies
whether ntd or some rbd controls
and
the percent blocking is shown here from
zero to a hundred and you can see
there's a large block that all
recognized the major anagenic site but
there's this one antibody 3434 that
recognizes its own site it only competes
with itself
and so we thought that was quite
interesting so by doing a hundred more
antibodies we found one
that was neutralizing and recognized a
unique site
if we
look um
again at the the distribution
of the 124 antibodies i mentioned
there's sort of what appears to be a
public clone type in fact the um
the
cdr3s are pretty diverse
as are the light chains so
there's something about the 124
heavy chain variable gene that is
beneficial but it's not a single
clonatype
when we look at the
and the phylogenetic these antibodies
and the
neutralizing ones that we see
and compared to all the sequences out in
sort of sequence space you do see that
both convalescent and vaccinated
individuals make a convergent antibody
response
um
using this variable gene so it's it's a
very dominant response and a lot of
people make it and we see it both in
convalescent and
in vaccinated individuals so that's the
gist of the work
we've looked at rbd analysis and ntd and
i think it just shows you that there's
the ability to do rapid
antibody response now to something that
occurs as you don't even anticipate and
and many of the things i've shown you
illustrate current principles of
antibody discovery
um in this day and age for viruses of
course good time science is team science
this is a picture of our team
uh in
2019 at the very end right before all
this happened
when we were not yet wearing masks
i mentioned many of the collaborators
even evelyn georgiev michael diamond at
washu ralph barrica unc dan baruch and
beth israel
we've done
escape mutation mapping with jesse
bloom's lab i i alluded to that but
didn't
speak of that
sample
collaborations from union lee
emery helen chu and mario ostrowski of
toronto
uh the pharma development that um i
discussed uh with astrazeneca as was led
by mark esser
uh and his team of very talented
antibody developers and clinical
trialists
freeman lab at
maryland did neutralizations with us and
peyong she
gave strains we've worked with many
companies in this work especially
berkeley lights i want to thank them for
their great collaboration also 10x
genomics helped us in the heat of the
moment with
um
with expertise and extra instruments
twist bioscience has been a great
partner for synthesis we've gotten
funding from nih
merc future insight prize darpa p3
um
niaid has been a
funder of this work
and then three company partners
astrazeneca id biologics zoology and
even our local celebrity dolly parton
contributed this work and thank you for
spending time with us and
listening this work and i appreciate
your attention
and
hope you enjoy the rest of the lab roots
conference
bye-bye